our chaps were to pick our fifa ultimate
team of the year obviously on the
chairman so I run what goes on his table
let's do it firstly goalkeeper lawyer
for me personally he's altered the
position everyone's compared in all the
keepers now to what Noah there's the way
you sweeps in behind his back for oars
back free whatever he plays in behind so
moving on we'll go to the right back
area Kyle Walker euro at a pitch who's
your mom I think it's the best fullback
in the world in lob his runs in getting
forward in everything I think it's
second to none I read something about
pep guardiola saying he's the most
intelligent footballer he's ever coached
saying that when he's a chubby yes
there's no coach mirrors here it's a
left-back where'd you go the article
tomorrow cello really I wouldn't this
aimless Joey you know I think for me
smart you Premiership boys a guy get on
da right so we're gonna go now to
central defence that's where I played
ball put the boy in your cool Jeremy I
would strongly push for for Sergio Ramos
cuz he gives you the goal threat me I
went to other silver Amy's a leader and
this force is a great defender on free
far you know I've got it is he oh he's
known as I never pick'em midfielders
where you are i'm looking at a free that
will cause ultimate damage and that's
how what has on any lee esta Joey Tony
Cruz technician keys a ball for fun Nick
year ago when you need to set play
delivery my overall ms dimaria european
cup winners medal argentina get to the
World Cup final okay we've got Pogba be
Maria Tony Cruz dictator oh yeah period
that like yeah I'm cool we're done
alright so this is where you come in now
we're gonna go to the attacking end of
the field if we're not all agree number
two you know perfection and perfection
who's better Ronaldo or messy okay first
I think that Messi's god-given ran out
of work for me I think renau don't is
complete if we're gonna say who's the
best player of last year what's
although hands down sounds like but
other than any debate we're gonna pull
up minimally who's the other guy gonna
be where uh oh grandma moolah humph
about but I'm gonna give my mom
we're at know you're in go right back
alarm left back and watch other Thiago
Silva and Ramos as a center are three
midfielders Pogba Tony Cruz and dimaria
and then we went up front humana Guerra
yeah shadowed by another messy there you
ever lose the manager who's the manager
I'm managing Ultimate Team legends only
on xbox